aps la droite qui a gagné au sénat c'est
le droit de gérard larcher s'est pas
celle de laurent wauquiez et ça c'est
quand même quelque chose d'important
dans les analyses et il faut la droite
modérée ou ligue 1 ça veut dire que
c'est la droite intelligente qui sait
faire preuve de sagesse comme on dit si
bien ici au sénat et qui sera travaillé
avec intelligence avec le gouvernant moi
je connais bien gérard larcher mon
amitié pour lui n'est un secret pour
personne je connais bien la plupart des
sénateurs qui ont été élus quelle que
soit d'ailleurs les tendances politiques
dimanche dernier je sais qu'on pourra
trouver un terrain d'entente ne sais pas
si c'est le mot mais d'accord politique
intelligente service des français et ça
c'est quand même aussi quelque chose
qu'il faut dire qu'on dit pas assez
depuis dimanche et s'installe avec les
réalités d'aujourd'hui prend la tête du
parti
je moi je regarde ce qui est j'entends
comme les autres et je vois bien les
postures politiciennes et compris
parfois chez certains de ses amis à
l'assemblée nationale on est dans la
petit khairi on est dans la politique à
l'ancienne on tourne le dos parfois
l'intérêt général c'est chose à
d'ailleurs me blesse moi qui ai milité
pendant longtemps aux républicains mais
voilà je tiens à le dire avant ça veut
dire si laurent wauquiez prend la tête
du parti comme annoncé en décembre vous
quitterez les républicains pour la dea
la république en marche comme l'a fait
votre ami bruno le maire
je sais pas ce que je ferais une chose
est sûre c'est plus le temps passe plus
je me pose effectivement la question de
ce que font et de ce que deviennent les
républicains ne pas savoir trancher
choisir entre marine le pen et emmanuel
macron entre les deux tours de
l'élection présidentielle
aujourd'hui après plus de dix ans
meeting dans lequel on dit qu'il fallait
assouplir le droit du travail réformée
lisf baisser les charges sur les
entreprises installées restaurer
l'autorité de l'état comme gérard
collomb le fait avec son projet de loi
de lutte contre le terrorisme de voir
que une partie de la droite s'opposent
pour au final leur s'abstenir dans
l'hémicycle où voter pour très
franchement ça veut dire merci à la
réalité c'est qu'il va falloir qu'il a
répondu à fasse preuve de clarté et
surtout soit en cohérence avec ce que
veulent les français